jack carrington is an excellent teacher
and he's about to teach you how to
develop web apps with micro front-ends
i'm jack harrington i was a principal
engineer at nike and also at walmart
labs and i'm here to talk to you about
what micro front ends are and get you up
to speed on that so why do you want to
do that well lots of fortune 500
companies are very interested in a topic
of microfinance and there's a good
reason for that so in this video i'm
going to walk you through micro front
ends all the way from tip to tail but as
anybody who has watched my channel
before which is linked to in the
description they'll know that i like to
entertain as much as i like to educate
so i'm gonna do a good action movie
trope and jump you right into the heart
of the action before backtracking and
laying the foundation so let me get you
excited about micro friends first and
then i'll talk to you about what comes
next so don't worry in this first
section if you get confused it'll all be
clear by the end so let's jump right
into vs code right now
i'm over in vs code and i'm going to
bring up the terminal actually i'm going
to bring up two terminals
and we're going to go build two apps so
in this first terminal i'm going to run
pmpx
and then create mf app
so pnpx is like mpx if you have npx just
use that
and create mf app is for create module
federation app so in this case i'm going
to pick the name of my host and i'm
going to call this one home because this
is going to be the home page app i'm
going to choose this an application on
port 3000
i'm going to use react and javascript
and also tailwind
now this other terminal i'm going to do
exactly the same thing i'm going to do
pmpx again and create mf app
and in this case i'm going to call the
application pdp or an ecommerce world
product detail page
and application and this one's going to
go on 3001 because you can't have it on
the same port again it's going to be
react javascript and tailwind
and again i'm going to go into that
directory and do exactly the same thing
i'm going to yarn and if that's
successful then yarn start
okay my home page is running let's go
back over to my browser and it shows me
that i now have an app it's called
home the framework is react language
javascript and it's tailwind for the css
and there's exactly the same thing on
port 3001 except that it's pdp
so let's say that we are the home page
team
these are managed by two different teams
and we are going to take on the task of
building the header so i'm going to
create a file here called header.jsx i'm
going to import react
from react
and i'm going to export a default
function
called header
and it's going to return some html out
of there
and it's going to have a div that's got
some
tailwind on it
let's see it's got some padding it's got
a background it's blue some text that's
white and large and it's in bold font
and i'm going to call this fidget
spinner world
because our app is going to be selling
fidget spinners
all right so let's go back over here and
create a new file called footer.jsx and
do pretty much exactly the same thing
and we're going to put in here
only the best spinners because that's
our motto we only sell the best spinners
and we'll say that that's the footer
and now let's go over to our app and
let's bring these components in just as
you would any normal react components so
header we're going to bring in from that
header file
and footer we're going to bring in from
the footer file
and i'm just going to drop these down
here header
and then footer
and in here i'm just going to say that
we have the homepage content so we'll
start off with a class name or you give
it a little margin vertically
and we'll say that this is the home page
content
and wrap that div up and let's take a
look
yeah okay looks good i'm gonna remove
the little top
margin there and
beautiful page okay so now the pdp team
is like okay we're going to start
implementing but we really don't want to
actually redo the header we want to use
your header so can we do that quickly
well absolutely we can because we can
turn our header
on this home page and the footer into
micro front ends and we can share them
with the pdp page really simply so let's
give that a try so i'm going to go into
a file here webpack config so this is
the webpack configuration
i'm going to scroll down here to the
module federation plugin
and i'm going to say that this
application which is named home
exposes
the header and the footer so we're going
to give it the name header and this is a
object where you give it the key which
is the expose
name
and then
the location of the module or the file
in this case that you want to expose so
then in this case we're doing the header
and then we're doing the footer it's a
good idea to keep the names obviously
the same between those two don't want to
confuse anybody
great so the only thing we need to do
now
is just restart
home
so now i'm on the home terminal and i'm
going to restart that so i'm going to
say yarn start again because we need to
reload that webpack configuration
but once we run it we can see that it
works just fine but there is something
new that's been added and that is a
remote entry file so in localhost 3000
there's also remoteentry.js
and that is a manifest of all of the
modules that are exposed by the homepage
application so i'm going to copy that
link
and then i'm going to go over to our pdp
application
into the webpack config
and scroll down here
and i'm going to say that we have a
remote
and that remote is home
and its
url is well home at and then i give it
that remote entry url now why home well
that's the same home as defined in this
webpack config as the name right here
and the only requirements on this is it
has to be a valid javascript variable
name so you can't use things like dashes
it can't be home page it could be home
underscore page that's fine because it's
a valid javascript variable so we're
going to use home
and now this is going to allow us to
access any of the exposed components
from home
but of course we have to restart the
server again so let's go over here to
pdp and then we'll restart the server
just to get that webpack configuration
loaded
and now if i go over here to our home
page and grab app like that
and copy out this because i'm kind of
lazy and i don't want to retype all that
stuff
i'm going to go over here to our pdp and
go to the app which looks almost
identical because it came out of the
same template i'm going to paste that in
there and i'm going to say pdp page
content and i'm going to hit save
will that work
let's try it out okay okay so i can't
resolve the header and the footer
obviously okay so there's no local
header and footer but if i do
home here
and i save
and i go back in here we can see now
we're serving the pdp page content and
we have our header and our footer the
exact same header and footer that came
out of the home page
awesome and even better check this out
so you go to header here and i say
fidget spinner world 2 the fidget
spinner world thing
and i do
refresh here awesome i get that
as i would expect and i go over to pdp
and without any restart or refresh or
code change or anything like that other
than hitting refresh in the browser
i get the updated content
so that's a runtime connection between
these two applications okay so let's
have a look at our completed application
that you will have by the end of this
video and of course all of the code is
available to you on github and let's
talk about why micro fees are so
important and why companies are really
invested in them so first off this is
our application you can see that this is
the completed home page
this is on port 3000 as we started
before and it's got our all of our
fidget spinners and it's got our header
it's not like a cart link on it it's got
a way to log in
there's a product detail page that shows
the detail around one of our spinners
and there's a cart page that shows you
all the products that are in your cart
so the reason that big companies are
interested in microphone ends is the
same reason that big companies are
interested in micro services when it
comes to the back end so on the back end
used to have monolithic api servers and
that meant that a bunch of teams were
working on a single code base that had a
single deploy cycle and
the microservice revolution allowed that
to change so now
every team could manage its own server
and update independently micro front
ends bring that same methodology to the
front end meaning that every one of
these applications home page pdp and
cart are managed by separate teams
and now they can go and deploy
independently and then if they vend out
any micro front ends that are consumed
by other teams those are automatically
updated
when they deploy so for example in this
case the cart team manages this little
cart drop down over here and whenever
the cart application deploys that cart
gets update updated along with it and
all of the other applications reuse that
cart and so it's done dynamically so not
only can the teams manage their own
applications but they can actually
manage
smaller pieces of the ui so now the
question becomes
when do you decide what is a micro fee
and what is not let's jump back over
here to the atomic design methodology so
the atomic design methodology
pioneer by brad frost basically defines
how uis are structured so you start with
atoms which in this case would be things
like a button or a label
or
something very small like an image
and then there's molecules which are
slightly larger components
that
use a bunch of those atoms for example a
labeled input which may use a label as a
text and then an input as well and it
manages the relationship between those
usually just statelessly
and then there's organisms
and in this case an organism would be
something like this cart drop down over
here so it's a self-contained piece of
ui that manages its own state and
understands how to bring together all
the molecules and atoms to get something
done so in this case that would be these
text fields are here the clear card and
the checkout and it's this unit of ui
the organism that i think is most
appropriate for sharing as a microphone
end i don't think that you should run
time share atoms and molecules that's
just my personal opinion but that's
where i kind of draw the line now
there's also
templates and pages
those don't really categorize for me as
micro fees but they are things that you
can share in fact when we talk about
micro front ends more in this video and
as we go along we'll be talking about
the underlying technology here which is
module federation and module federation
actually allows you to share a lot more
than just microphone ends in fact we'll
actually start off by sharing some
functions and then we'll get into
components and then we'll get into
sharing full page contents and routing
so it's really exciting stuff okay i've
introduced you to the world of
microphone ends and why they're
important to companies let's now talk
about module federation and what it is
and why it's different from other
techniques of sharing code so module
federation is a feature that's built
into webpack 5. it's absolutely free and
it is part of the standard webpack 5
deployment now so anything that's built
on top of webpack 5 can use module
federation as you saw from that pnpx
i've actually got it set up so you can
use well 10 different view templates
right now and there's also angular and
other frameworks that can also use
module federation so module federation
can be applied to pretty much every
popular view framework it's great stuff
so let's talk a little bit about why
it's different from other methodologies
of sharing and to do that i'm going to
close out these and i'm going to
get us into the kind of architectural
box layer we're going to do that
together
so we're going to do
file here it's going to be called
architecture.do i have a visual studio
extension draw.i o extension allows me
to kind of draw diagrams and and go all
full architecture mode right inside my
vs code let me just drop in here what we
started with right so we've got the
homepage app that currently is at 1.0
and we've got the pdp app over here and
inside the home app we have the header
and the footer so now let me go and
build out the mpm version of this i'm
going to create a new page we're going
to call this mpm
i'm going to paste these two in
and then i'm going to bring in a box for
the mpm library right
so this is going to be our mpm
library and it's going to kind of sit
somewhere between these two
and then we're going to take the header
and the footer and we're going to put it
into our mpm library and we're going to
arrange it to bring it to the front so
it all makes sense looking good okay
great
so now we have extracted our header and
our footer into our npm library now we
got to reuse those so i'm going to go
and draw a link between
the
home page app and the npm library and
i'm going to do the same thing with the
pdp app all right so drop that in there
those are looking good i want to move
this around a little bit to get these
arrows nicely lining up okay cool so
let's say now that we are a developer on
the home page app
and as part of the homepage team our job
is also to maintain the header and the
footer in this shared npm library and so
i get a juror ticket saying hey we need
to go and change this you know text or
whatever now i've got to go and jump
from where i'm normally working which is
the homepage app working on features in
that app and i got to jump over to this
mpm library which may have not been
worked on in a long time because the
header doesn't update all that often
and i've got to go and do that
change and then i'm going to bump that
version to
1.0.1 and publish that out to our local
arc repository
and on the homepage app i'm then going
to bump that to 1.0.1 which is going to
then
grab the mpm library and
release to production
it's kind of a hassle
same sort of thing over here and then
have to go and talk to the pdp team and
say hey there's a new version of the
header please use it and they would go
and bump it and there you go but now
from the customer perspective
right i'm on the home page and i click
into a product i'm actually now going to
get an older version of the header on
the pdd page app which may actually not
be great at all
in a black friday situation at a major
e-commerce company they're going to be
making changes all over the place all
the time and so
when they
make a change the header they're going
to want to see that happen immediately
between these two pages so how we're
going to solve that requirement well
let's go back over here and see
what we can do and talk about some
solutions that i've seen in the industry
and one of the most popular is to use
something along the lines of an asset
store so we'll call this the asset store
option
and again we'll start off with our 1.0
and 1.0 as we have before and kind of
bring these down a little bit and widen
out the space because we need some space
and so now we're going to bring in this
header footer project
and the idea of the header of the footer
project
is to
contain that header in that footer
and we'll bring those to the front so we
can see them
again oh my gosh you got to make some
more space here
all right over here boy drawing diagrams
it's the the bane of architecture
and what this one's going to do this
header for the project is it's going to
build some s3 artifacts it's probably
going to build
a static version of the html and it's
going to build the js and then those are
basically going to be injected onto the
page so
we've now even removed react from the
equation here right this is just maybe
react that is rendered as static html
and then some helper javascript to
actually add some dynamic behavior
and that is then put up on s3
and so we'll draw an arrow between those
two things this thing is going to create
that s3 artifact in order to consume
that to make it easy on ourselves we're
going to go make a shim library so drop
that in here
and its job is to go and fetch
that content from s3 and its job is to
return to the home page app in the pdp
page app some html or some references
that it grabs from s3 that the home page
and pdp app then inject into their page
templates to drop the header onto the
page so these guys need a connection to
that shim library
and then the advantage with this one is
that this header and footer can then
update those s3 artifacts at any time
that shim library is designed to make
sure that you always are getting the
most recent copy
and that gives you your dynamic behavior
so this header footer project when those
late requests come in from product to
update the header immediately
the header footer project can then
deploy to s3 and all of those changes
will show up on the homepage and pdp
page automatically as long as they're
not caching those results you can see
there's a lot going on here and there's
a lot of custom work there's a lot of
custom ci cd these are very custom
pieces of work very diy that are company
specific and of course
having any developers move from the home
page and start making changes on the
header footer project because it's so
alien and maybe entirely written in a
different view framework
that's a big change so there's a lot of
context switching so you end up having a
team that's dedicated to that header
footer project it's
really just a large company option okay
so
what does
module federation bring to the party so
module federation let's go for the
module federation approach here
and we'll start again with our home page
and pdp page app
and in this case we have the home app
and we've got the header and the footer
and all the pdp page app needs to do is
just connect directly to
the header and the footer
just like that
and so
you get the dynamic behavior whenever
the homepage application pushes so it
goes up to a 1.01
the pdp page automatically
gets the new code
you're not changing
development environments those header
and footer components are still written
in react and as long as the pdp page is
also written in react then they work
right away so there's no issue there
with changing frameworks or
different packaging or whatever and also
the work is done in context meaning that
as a homepage app developer i just work
on the header directly and i just work
on the footer directly
and there is some risk there and we'll
talk about that in just a minute but
it's much lower in terms of context
shift cost when it comes to development
so you can see why
of these three methodologies module
federation is the most attractive when
it comes to sharing component code
all right let's put away our
architecture tools for a bit and let's
talk about some of the questions that i
get most often when it comes to module
federation and the first one is around
asynchronous stuff so how do i actually
include the header for example
asynchronously
so let's do that let me just show as
opposed to tell so i'm going to bring in
suspense from react
and here i'm going to say
const header
equals and then do react lazy
and i'm going to give it a function
and it's going to import the header
and it's going to do a dynamic import
this is absolutely standard it's an
asynchronous dynamic import
it works in react but it also works on
any other technology you have any type
of library you have
the special sauce here is in this react
lazy
and then we're going to wrap the header
in a suspense
and we're going to give it a fallback
saying that
while we're waiting
we should put in a div which says for
example loading that's a classic
fallback div
and so now let's restart our servers so
we're gonna go back over here to
our home and then start that
and then go to the pdp page and start
that
as we go through this by the way keep a
keen eye on this tab over here it's
really nice that it actually has the
names of the directory in there we're
gonna actually have five
running applications by the end of this
so we're gonna be doing a lot of jumping
around here
all right so here is our pdp page and as
we can see fidget spinner world is
running just fine
so that is asynchronously loaded but if
we kind of want to prove it to ourselves
let's go and make that stateful so i'm
going to go and
return this here
and then do use date
and we're going to say okay so we have
some state in here for showing the
header
and we'll use state for that
and we'll only show the header
if we are true
and then i'm gonna go make a button
it says show the header
and i'm gonna make it large
and give it some padding
just so we can see it
okay cool all right so the first thing
we need to do is start that off as false
right we don't want to show the header
by default and then if we get a click
here we're going to turn that to true so
unclick set show header to just true
really i'm not going to toggle it
there we go
all right so we haven't shown the header
so far so let's go over here to our
inspector and take a look at our network
and see what we got going on so i'm
going to refresh this and we're going to
see that
if i scroll down here we have loaded the
footer but we have not yet loaded the
header and when i click on show the
header over here we get the header
and actually let's go take a look at the
size on that it came in at 1.1
kilobytes
so that's another really important point
to module federation so if i look back
over here
at the webpack config we can see that
there's another key down here that i
haven't talked at all about which is the
shared key
and this is all of the libraries that
are shared
out of this home page so what it's doing
here is it's grabbing all the
dependencies by just looking at the
package.json and then getting the
dependencies
so it's going to share them all out
and then it's also going to share
as part of that react and react down but
it's going to override those to say that
they're shared in singleton mode which
means that there can only be
one react on the page at a time and
that's actually really important for
react because react does have some data
that's managed at the library level and
it is singleton in nature and so if you
have multiple instances of react on the
same page it kind of freaks out a little
bit and breaks so you don't want that so
webpack shares and manages that sharing
for you which is really awesome and
that's why
that
header only comes in at 1.1 kilobytes
all it's doing is just bringing in just
the component code for the header now if
there are any other dependencies that
header needed like moment or whatever it
would bring those in as well but only in
the case where you imported headers so
that's really handy
okay so now i'm not going to do this
this way so i'm going to go and kind of
unroll all this
and we'll just go back to plain old
header
and we'll talk about the next question
that i get when it comes to module
federation which is
what happens
when the app goes down
and the reason that i get this question
a lot is because this is the way that i
demonstrate module federation i run it
in apps
but that's not the way that you deploy
module federation so let's go and do
that let's actually take down home
and we'll go over here to pdp and we'll
see yeah it blows up absolutely 100 no
question yeah blows up let's see
script loading error couldn't load
header footer 100
absolutely so true
if my demo
app goes down right that's not
going
so true if my demo app goes down then
the sharing system goes down that's true
but that is not actually the way that
you're going to deploy
module federation and that's why this is
not really an issue but there is another
related issue that will get into us in a
second so the way that you deploy module
federation is you build and deploy it to
a static asset store like s3 because you
want to get that
akamai or cdn style caching and all that
kind of goodness so let's first build it
and that's created a local directory
called dist
so let's go in there and take a look at
what that is and it's got a bunch of js
files so there's really nothing unique
to this you don't actually have a server
in here so i'm going to use mpx and a
module called servor to run this
application on port 3000 which imitates
a static asset store right server
doesn't know anything other than just
serve these static files so it's just
like s3 in that case so now we've got
3000 back and running
and i'm going to do refresh and you're
good to go so
as long as s3 and your static asset
store don't go down
then you're not going to have an issue
when it comes to the code not being
there so that's not the risk that you
should be worried about the risk that
you should be worried about is that a
developer on the homepage team may
change the api contract of header and
make it work in home
but not actually tell the pdp page team
that the api contract is changing that
is the risk that you've got to worry
about so let's try that out and see how
this actually can blow up so first i
need to
get out of my sharing of the compiled
dist there
and then go back and do yarn start
and now we're sharing the live code
again
so now we'll go into header
and i'm going to do
app in here because the feature request
was to put the app name into the header
so this is going to say
app.name and i'm gonna save
and then i'm gonna refresh the homepage
and boom
what's the issue well the issue is that
we cannot read
name because the app is undefined right
there's no property we didn't put a
property called app on there so as the
developer on this jira i'm gonna go and
then say okay well i need to fix that
right so i'm gonna say app
name is
home
done okay
jira closed
pr reviewed done deployed uh
life is excellent next year please right
so okay but over on the pdp team we're
just swimming along doing our stuff and
we refresh the page and
blowing up right so why is that well we
didn't make the corresponding change on
our side
so
yes of course i can make the change on
the pdp page side and do all that
choreography but how do we actually
protect ourselves from that so that this
might potentially never happen well the
trick there is to use error boundaries
or some equivalent in whatever view
framework you're doing but in react
world we're going to use an error
boundary
so i'm going to create a new file
called safe component
and we're going to bring in react
and unfortunately an error boundary has
to be a class so we are going to
extend
save component from a react component
error boundaries are actually the one
case that i know of where you absolutely
have to use a class in react
now we're going to have a constructor
and it's going to set the state so that
there's a state value on this and it's
basically going to tell us whether an
error has occurred
and then we're going to add the two
methods that are specific to
a an error boundary the first is
component did catch which gets thrown
when the component catched and then
given the error we returned that our new
state is has error true right we can do
a lot more here we can
specify what the type of error is we can
console log it we can send it to you
know
splunk or whatever you can do all that
stuff i'm not gonna do that right here
i'm just gonna go and
render out something safe so let's go
make that render method
and basically i say well if we've had an
error then we're gonna do something went
wrong
otherwise we're just gonna return the
children okay so now let's go back over
to our pdp page and import our safe
component
from that save component file and then
we're going to wrap our header
in that save component
and
go over to here and we refresh and yes
something went wrong great
so now our page still runs
but it doesn't render the header now
there is a
fallback methodology that i've talked
about in a video on my channel where you
can use both module federation and mpm
so that in the case when something blows
up you actually fall back on an older
version that you got in mpm
that's a great
strategy too here really depends on how
far you want to go with this protection
so let's go back over into our homepage
and actually fix the bug and see that it
works so we're going to remove the app
here
and then go and remove the necessity for
the app over and header
take down our two
and
there you go
everything looks great all right so i've
introduced you to the world of
microfinance we've gone and built two
different applications already we've
talked about
why microphone ends are important what
module federation is how to handle
asynchronous loading and how to handle
error states
let's now actually start building out
our application and learn more about
module federation as we do so now to do
that
we need to actually go and build our api
server that's going to have our products
and it's going to have our cart now
yes i'm going to go and create a
monolithic single server for this i
didn't want to have six tabs
running but yes in the real world you
probably have multiple servers with
multiple data you know you'd have a
product server you'd have a cart server
and a user server and
all of that stuff but in this case we're
just going to have one server
all right so let's go back over into our
terminal and create yet another terminal
yeah we're going to have 5 by the end of
this
and again i'm going to do pmpx
now why pmpx by the way it's a windows
thing turns out i'm on mac but it turns
out that
pmpx is the way to go on windows who
knew
and if you're on windows you're like no
npx works just fine let me know but uh
i'm doing this for my
my friends in windows world so let's do
create mf app
and in this case i'm going to make it
server
and instead of application we're going
to go down here to api server i'm going
to put it on port 8080 you know as i
guess as usual when it comes to api
servers and what we're going to use as a
template is nest js with auth so this
one is going to use nest js as our api
server it's going to be a rest server
and we're going to use
jwt or jot based authorization and
that's the template for that one
so now i'm going to go into server
and i'm going to
yarn it get that all going
so let's take a look at what's in the
server we've got a public directory that
has
all the assets that we want to put in
there and you're going to be able to
find those on github but i'm just going
to add them locally so this is going to
have you know fidget 1.jpg nice cool
wagon wheel looking fidget spinner a
friend of mine is all into fidget
spinners so i figured this would be a
fun fun demo data piece
and we'll delete that and then if we go
yarn start here
we can
bring up localhost 8080
and then go to
fidget 1.jpg and awesome so now we know
that we're getting this
set of
static assets that's good
so now the next thing we need to do is
ensure that we can get the list of
products so over here we've got our auth
stuff we're not going to touch that that
is the jwt management we're not going to
touch users but i will show you that
there is two users that are kind of
baked into this there is sally who has a
password of one two three maria who has
a password of one two three you can as
many users as you like obviously this is
just demo stuff
you can hook this up to a real backend
if you ever want to
so
in modules we've got
two modules we've got authorized and
unauthorized so let's take a look at our
unauthorized controller
and what it's telling us is that we've
got a controller that's camping on
unauthorized and if i get it i'm going
to return true just a single return true
value so i'm going to do localhost 8080
and then do unauthorized and it's going
to turn
true
fabulous
okay
so what we want to do is change this
code so that instead of being
unauthorized it's products so first
we're going to change anything that says
unauthorized to products
and i'm going to make that lowercase
and this is going to break up all kinds
of stuff so i'm going to go over here to
unauthorized
change all that products
i'm going to change this directory name
to products
and change these file names
to products
and finally i'm going to go into app
module and change this to products
do the lower casing
all right let's take a look
i'm gonna do yarn start dev i think yeah
so this is going to continuously watch
the server for updates i didn't start in
that the first time
all right let's do this
localhost 8080
products
ah okay cool
returning true that's great awesome okay
so now i've got my routing set up
properly i've got the products
unauthorized route because we want to be
able to get products without actually
being logged in in this system we are
going to have to be logged in to add
items to our cart we're not going to
allow for anonymous carts you can do
that if you want
but beyond the scope of this
so the next thing we need to do is have
our product list
so that root level over here under
source i'm going to create a new file
called products.ts
i'm going to paste in our product
definitions again all of this is
available to you on github but let's
talk about a little bit about what a
product is so it's got an id it's got a
name
a price a description an image which is
the url to the local host and then the
long description
by the way i had some fun with gpt3 to
build out these long descriptions so if
there's some insane stuff in there you
can blame gbt3 for that all right so
let's go back over here to
our products module and controller and
then over in here we're going to import
those products
as well as the definition of a product
and it's not going to be from product
data
it's going to be from
products
cool
and this is going to return an array of
products
which is going to be from products so
let's save that out
and refresh and awesome so fast i love
it ness js is actually really cool if
you get into server work
i strongly recommend checking out an sjs
and of course graphql
all right so let's go back over here to
visual studio code and then add another
method
so this is going to be able to get by a
particular id so in sjs world you give
it this decorator for the route that you
want so in this case it's colon id
basically going to map that id onto the
parameter it's gonna be a string
we're then going to go in through the
list of products and find
that product id
and we're gonna parse out that string to
a number okay
so let's go back over here and do
instead of products we're going to do
products
one and that just pairs it down to the
one product let's do product id i guess
10. there you go gold and silver gears
at 9.99
awesome
excellent so that's pretty much all we
need to do for the server at this point
let's jump back over to the client and
get that going
all right so let's close down that
window close down server go over to home
and then here we're going to create a
new file called products.js
and we're going to specify our api
server is going to be at localhost 8000
and then we're just going to use fetch
to go and get the list of products so
it's going to fetch
off of 8080 slash products and then it's
just a return a promise which has the
json
out of it so that's going to give us
back our list of products
but while we're here let's go and add
another one for getting a particular
product by id so get product by id and
that's going to be used by the pdp page
so when they want to get data on their
product they just have a particular
product in mind right they've got slash
product slash one they're going to go
and give us the id and then we're going
to get back the data that's specific to
that by calling that
by id endpoint that we created
and then because i'm a big fan of using
code i'm also going to bring in a
currency converter which just uses intel
and we're going to use the us us dollars
currency so that when we format the
prices nicely you know make it look
great
all right so let's go over to our app
page and we're going to do this a little
bit differently so i'm going to create a
homepage content component and i'm going
to bring it into this home page content
area and there's a good reason for that
but it's always good to not have mega
components anyway so i'm going to do a
new file here
and say homecontent.jsx
and i'm going to bring in the usual
react
and use state
and use effect
and then i'm also going to bring in
products by the way if you're wondering
how i'm getting that awesome hinting
that's actually github copilot
and then i'm going to start our home
content component it's going to have
our product list in use date
and then to go get that i'm going to use
a use effect
use effect takes a function
which is the effect that you want to
affect and then it takes a dependency
array so in this case the dependency
array is empty because we want to have
this run only once
and then i'm going to get products
and once i get that value back because
that's a then it's a promise i'm going
to set that products
all right so let's start off on our jsx
so i'm going to
put some jsx in there that's got
it's got some y padding on it and it's
like grid layout so it's going to have
four across so that's why grid calls
four with a little gap in between each
one i love tail one so expressive
and then with each of the products i'm
going to
run a map
and put the key on there for the product
id
and then let's try it out so we're going
to go in over into our app
and we're going to bring in our home
content
from that home content file
and then i'm gonna put it in there for
the home page content
and now i don't need that extra y
padding i've already got that
so let's take a look let's hit refresh
hey
cool so that's making the connection to
our api server and putting up our
beautiful fidget spinners i really
should be getting into these like
more than i look at them
i spent multiple days with this example
and i'm like oh wow
maybe reward myself with the fidget
spinner
all right let's continue on so let's go
back over to our home content
and i'm going to
paste in here
that we want a flexbox and that flexbox
is going to have a name on it
so let's take a look
oh nice adding in our name looks good
and let's go add the price in there and
make that the next element in our
flexbox it's going to use our currency
formatter to format our product price
into us dollars so let's take a look
pretty nice okay cool
and i think the last thing we need to do
is just add a description so the
customer knows what they're buying
let's drop that in there
yeah looks pretty good
text is a little large but that's okay
all right so our teams are in the mode
of sharing and our pdp page wants to
reuse our get product by id
function
to
get the product by id
and that's one of the great things about
module federation is that not only can
you use it to share components but you
can use it to share any type of
javascript it could be constants it
could be
encoded json it could be functions it
can be components it can be whatever
kind of javascript you want so in this
case we're also going to share out our
products
library i guess file module
from our home app so let's go back over
here to webpack config and scroll down
again to exposes and all we need to do
is just add in products
and then say that it's products.js
all right let's say that out and again i
have to
reboot home because the webpack
configuration has changed
and now over on the pdp side we can
start doing the same thing so i'm going
to go and close out these files
and i'm going to go over here into the
pdp content
and i'm going to create a new file and
we're going to call this pdp content
dot jsx
and into that i'm going to also bring
use state and use effect because we're
going to do pretty much exactly the same
thing we're going to hard code
right now that our product is one
and let's go over here to our app and
bring in that pdp content
from that pdp content file and let's go
and pop that down in there for its
content
let's take a look
there we go product one as you'd expect
okay so let's start bringing in the code
to get that product we'll go back over
here to our pdp content
it'll bring in our
get product by id and also our currency
formatter from home but instead of
header or footer in this case we're just
going to use products like we did before
so let's save and if this doesn't work
it's going to blow up right now so it's
no it looks like it's going to be good
okay great
all right so let's change this to id
and then i'm going to drop in here some
state so we're going to say that this is
going to be thus the product we've
actually gotten
and put in here id at the moment and
we're just going to say if we don't have
a product
then we're going to return null
and so right now it's going to return
nothing and so we're empty in there
and so now we need to bring in a use
effect so we're going to bring in a use
effect we're going to say okay so if we
have an id which is specified as once
we're going to have one
then we're going to go and get that
product by that id and with that product
we're going to set that product so in
fact let's simplify this code even a
little bit more we'll just say set
product
all right take a look oh looks like
we're good okay so i think we probably
got the data in fact we probably just do
at this point product.name
yeah wheel spinner good to go
so let's start laying out our nifty ui
in here we'll just replace all this
and we'll have a
two column layout this time with a
little gap in between
and then we'll have our product image in
the
left hand side so let's hit save and
there you go well looking pretty good so
far cool
so let's get to getting on that right
hand side and we're going to bring in a
div that's got
a flex box
and it's going to have our product name
that's expandable thus the flex grow and
it's going to be nice and big
and then at the end of whatever that is
we're going to have the currency
formatted for the currency price
that looks good 5.99 are you out of your
mind
and let's bring in the description
huh pretty good and then let's bring in
the long description
generated by gpt3
all right here we go i just you know i'm
not a good copywriter like that
our wheel spinner is fun functional it
actually looks really good it's amazing
how much gp23 was able to deduce just
from like a wheels fidget spinner that
spins with it basically i gave it that
and it gave me this which is
crazy
okay so next thing we want to do is
allow for us to do like product one like
that now
the
webpack configs are actually set up if
we did go take a look at them
with
history api fall back to true which
basically means that any route that
isn't served from some sort of static
asset is going to just render the same
application in the dev server mode so
that's why you can basically give this
any url you want you know any url and
it's just going to go and and give you
the same page over and over and over
again so that that's why we can use
something like react router dom to
actually select out different products
so what we want is we want to be able to
say you know 10 for example here and get
10 as opposed to our hard-coded
one which is we have now
so let's go and stop our pdp server
and now we're going to go add
react
router dom
and i'm going to do a yarn start again
and then over in our app
i'm going to go and bring in our react
router dom stuff let's get rid of
suspense there we no longer need that
we're no longer suspenseful
and we're going to wrap this whole thing
in
router
and we i'm not going to do the safe
component stuff it's fine it's safe as
is
not planning on blowing anything up
and now inside here you're going to put
the switch so this is where we're going
to change out the content and in react
router dom world you use a switch for
that
and then inside of that you've got a
route
and
we're going to say that the path is
going to be something along the lines of
slash product
and then an id
and then the
component that is going to be
rendered if we have that is the pdp
content component so let's hit save
there
and see if this works let's go i'm going
to close out that we don't need that
anymore and yeah it works fine but if we
go to like for example just slash right
that doesn't match
this path pattern here so you're not
going to get anything so let's go back
to product 10 and that works fine
because that matches slash product slash
id so how do we go and get that id well
let's go back over here to our pdp
content and i'm gonna go bring in use
params
from
react router
dom
all right
and that's actually pretty easy so i'm
just gonna put in their id and then use
use params that because use program you
could have multiple parameters so this
is going to return you an object which
we want to destructure and get out the
id
so there you go save that out
oh wow that is pretty
that may be the one i get
so i've got our home page we've got our
product detail page we're showing the
customers a bunch of these fidget
spinners but now we want to be able to
sell the customers some fidget spinners
we've got an e-commerce app after all so
we want to do some commerce so that
means that they need to have a way to
log in and have a way to add and remove
and view their cart
so why am i doing all this on e-commerce
stuff and using this example well this
is going to allow us to explore how to
share a state between the host and the
remote so let's talk a little bit about
the nomenclature there so when it comes
to our header for example the home page
is the remote
and then the
pdp page is the host
so the pdp page is hosting
the header that is remote to it and it's
remoted in essentially from the home
page so when i talk about host and
remote that's that relationship and in
this case we want to talk about
exploring how to share state between the
host page
and the
remote that's coming in so
we're going to have a way to log in to
our server to get a jot back the jwt or
json web token not sure is why it's
pronounced jot as opposed to whatever
but that's going to be our
authentication and we're going to want
to share that between the host page
which is going to want to know if it
should add like for example the add to
cart buttons
and the cart mfe which is going to show
you your cart so the mfe is going to
want to know that you have a jot and the
host page is going to want to know that
you want to have a jot and you're also
going to be able to share the cart items
between the different parts of the
system so we're going to explore using
this shared state okay so let's jump in
and start working on building out our
cart and that means going back to our
server
and working on that so over on our
server
we have
modules and we got this authorized
module and if we go down we look at the
the readme
we can see
some documentation on how to
use the authorization part of this so
for example
i'm going to create yet another terminal
and i'm going to follow this example
here that's the example is to do curl
and hit up this
localhost 8080 authorized route which
means that i need to have some
authentication details to hit that route
i don't yet so that's going to give me
401 message unauthorized
so what i can do is i can post
to login
with the username and password and i'm
going to get back a jot so i'm going to
copy and paste this again this is just
in the readme
and paste that in there
and that gives us back an access token
and that is our jot
now how does that work well ness js has
a whole section in its documentation on
how to do authorization and you pretty
much just follow that and it'll give you
this auth login and then you can specify
some users of course you can go get them
for anywhere but again i've gone put in
there
maria in one two three and that's what
we're passing in here in marien123 and
that gives you back this job
all right so then let's go back into our
readme again and see what i can do with
that jot
well i can scroll down
and i'm going to copy this line which
just starts off with the same thing we
did before with authorized but now we're
going to give an additional header and
that header is going to say
authorization and it's going to give it
a bearer
and then i'm going to just
paste that
and i'm going to copy
the jot that we got back all the way up
to but not including
the
quote i'm going to paste that in there
and paste in put in the quote there and
we're going to go back that way our user
id is 2.
and so why are we getting that back well
let's go take a look at our authorized
route here
so go into the controller
and we'll see that when we
get
we use a guard and that's basically
saying okay guard this method by
applying that jot our j280
and that particular off guard
and that's going to give us a request
when we get run and we pass that jot
and from that jot we're going to get the
user and the user id so that's pretty
easy right
okay so the first thing we need to do is
kind of what we did with products but
now we need to do with authorized so
we're going to need to change all that
stuff that says authorized to cart
cart
here cart there cart here and everywhere
and we'll change the name to cart
directory and we'll change the file
names to cart and we'll change this to
cart
okay looking pretty good
we don't put more carts in here
seems to be okay at this level let's go
back up to our app module that's the
last place that actually does it
see i'm going to change authorized
to
cart
and then
lowercase that cart
and hit save
and let's see i can actually test this
out by going up here
and doing exactly the same thing as
before
except instead of authorized i'm going
to do cart
and if i've made all the changes
correctly yes
that's good okay so now
we're working on the cart route that's
great so we've changed the route
successfully
and now we just need to kind of upgrade
this cart controller with our cart
functionality because obviously
returning a user ids is not what we want
right we have the jot functionality we
can now log in we need to actually
maintain a cart
so i'm going to start by bringing in the
list of products as well as the
interface for a cart so a cart is going
to have multiple cart items it's going
to have array of cart items
and those cart items are going to extend
the product they're going to be an exact
replica
of the product data but with an
additional quantity how many of the
fidget spinners do you want right so the
cart is basically going to have
everything that you need to know to
render out the contents of the card it's
going to have all the product
information plus
the quantity that you want
and then i'm going to bring in a little
helper function here called initial cart
and this is going to take a list of
indices so this is the
references into
the products they want to kind of
preload the cart for our particular
users so we're going to give maria some
stuff in her cart already and sally some
stuff in her cart already just so it's a
little bit easier to test
and we're gonna store that down here in
our cart controller as a private member
variable it's gonna be called carts
and sally is id number one and she's
gonna have an initial cart that has uh
items 0 2 and 4 in it and maria is going
to have items 1 and 3.
okay so the first thing we need to do is
return what's in the cart so we're going
to use this get method
and we're just going to return
whatever is in the cart of that
particular user id so again sally's
number one so that's going to map to
there and marie's number two and it's
coming after there
we're not going to return a number we're
going to return a cart
so we're going to turn a promise to
return a cart
so let's try this again
and there you go cool okay so now i've
tried it again with
the jot that we got back before which
has a long expiration it's got a 24-hour
expiration on it so it's not going to go
anywhere
and it's returning to us the contents of
that person's cart
that's a pretty good start we're doing
great so now the next thing we need to
do is have a method where you can post
to that endpoint and add an item to the
cart and then also a delete and delete
an item from the cart so let's
go back in here
so we're going to create a post method
and we need to bring in post from our
nest.js
and it's great you're learning full
stack at the same time that you're
learning about all this micro fee stuff
so there's so many good things to learn
here about
jot authentication and all the rest of
it okay so we have a now post method
same idea so you just post
to that same endpoint again it's going
to be auth guarded with the jot i'm
going to get that request it's coming in
before but this time we're going to say
that our body contains an id and that's
the id of the product
that we want to add and then it's going
to return
the new cart the updated cart
so first we need to get your cart
and we use the same thing we did here
with this.carts and give it the user id
and then we need to see if you already
have an item in your cart because we're
just going to update the quantity if you
have that item otherwise we're going to
add a new item to your cart
so we have a cart item we're just going
to add update the quantity
otherwise we are going to add on to your
cart items by pushing
the product and then a quantity one
right cool and then we're just going to
return that cart
easy peasy lemon squeezy and the next
thing we need to allow is the removal of
the carton for this i have personally
decided to use the delete method
on that you know
is that the right thing to do i don't
know i
you know that's really up to you but i'm
going to just use delete for that
and again it's going to be auth guarded
because we need well one to know the
user id and of course we want
everybody's cart to remain their own and
secure and all we're going to do is just
basically if you get a delete on that
endpoint we're going to look to get the
user id and we're going to set the cart
to an empty cart and return it just like
that
okay we're pretty good so i think our
cart functionality is going great so now
the next thing we need to do is actually
have a cart app the third app here to
connect this to
so i'm going to go back over into our
terminal and you know what i'm just
going to reuse this terminal we've been
playing around with to do another one of
these pnpxs with that create mf app
and i'm going to call this one cart
and it's also going to be a react app so
i'm going to call this one cart
it's going to be an application that
sits on port 3002
and it's going to react javascript and
tailwind
and we can talk a little bit about why
i'm not using create react app or next
js for this obviously i'm using react so
why am i not using one of those well
create react app and next have very
complex setups everything's in there
with
a really complex web webpack
configuration
and eslint and testing
and prettier and all the rest of it and
that's great it's a great starting point
but it's a lot of extra clutter and
bloat that distracts from what i want to
do with create mf app which is give you
a way to make proof of concept and test
applications so you can test out how
module federation and micro fees are
going to work in your environment
without actually going and making all
the adjustments to those things yourself
so each one of the apps that it creates
is the smallest possible thing that i
can think of it's basically just webpack
and x webpack and react webpack and view
webpack and lit webpack and all of the
different there's 10 different templates
that you can use so you know
it's very very simple and lightweight
and it's all there for you to try out
and play with
okay so it looks like we've installed
properly so the next thing i'm going to
add to our client is i'm going to add
rxjs
well what is rxjs and why am i adding it
so rxjs is a set of reactive
objects and functions
it's a very
elaborate system for creating observable
streams
so
in our case we're just going to use it
really simply we're going to create a
behavior subject which is a type of
observable that's going to hold our jot
our jwt our json web token and another
one that's going to hold our cart
and the nice thing about it is you can
always get the current value and you can
subscribe to it so when it changes
you get to see it and the other nice
thing about rxjs is it's not bound to
any view framework so we are going to
use a different view framework here
pretty soon coming up and if i'd chosen
something that was bound to react
then that would be a problem whereas in
this case anything that can run a
subscribe method on an object is going
to be able to listen to the jot and be
able to listen to
the cart and that means it could be
anything could be vanilla js it could be
solid it could be
inferno it could be all kinds of
different things so okay so it looks
like we're good we've added our rxjs
so now i'm going to start up our app
okay great so just like we had before
very simple vanilla startup with the
tailwind stuff and makes it easy to
put some nice styling on it
okay so we're going to go over here to
our cart into a source and i'm going to
create a new file and it's going to be
called cart.js and this is going to
manage in much the same way that
products manage our connection to the
products portion of the server this is
going to manage our connection to the
cart and authentication side of the
server so we're going to bring in rxjs
we're going to give ourselves that
constant api server which can point to
the api server and we're going to create
that behavior subject for the j2at so
that's going to have if i do jwt.value
it's going to tell me what the current
value of that jot is which in this case
is give me null and if i do subscribe
on this and i put in there token or
something like that and i say you know
console.log token
it's going to get called every time that
a new value goes into jot and the way
that a new value goes in there is you
say wwt.next and you give it the new
value
like that so it's a pretty simple
api surface here you do next to give it
to publish a value to give it a new
value you do subscribe to listen to
changes and then you can do value at any
time to get the current value so very
very simple way of sharing state now
on my channel in my module federation
playlist there's
coverage of redux and a whole bunch of
different state managers when it comes
to doing this with module federation but
i want to keep it really simple and this
one so is rxjs
so what's the first thing we need to do
well we need to go and log in so let's
go and bring in our login
and our login is going to take a
username and a password it's going to do
a fetch a little bit more elaborate this
time because it's going to post as
opposed to get it's got some headers
and it's going to need to send along the
username and the password
and then it's going to get back the
response we're going to assume that it's
okay i'm not going to do any any error
routes on this but of course you would
need to
and then
that jdt.next is what i'm going to call
when i get back the access token from
the payload because we saw when we did
the curls ourselves that the access
token is the key that we get back from
the server that has that jot in it
okay so let's start building out our ui
we're going to actually go and log in at
this point so let's go and close this
out and i'm going to go over to our pack
config and of course we need the header
and the footer
and for this one i'm just going to add
all of these apps together so i'm going
to have a route for home i'm going to
have a route for pdp and i'm going to
have a route for myself
so i can be self-referential on cart so
if i internally use cart slash it's just
going to loop back onto myself and
module federation happily supports that
so the next thing we need to do is
create a new file called cart content
dot jsx
and into that i'm going to create a cart
content it's going to be a similar thing
to what we had before so it's going to
have some state that's going to have
that token
on it and we're going to do that login
but before we get there let's go and
make sure that that actually works so
i'm gonna bring in the header and the
footer from home i'm gonna bring in our
cart content
and then i'm just gonna replace our body
content with pretty much the same thing
as we've had in all the other apps which
is
the
wrapper and then the header and the
footer and then our cart content
all right so let's take a look at what
it looks like and it looks like we're
blowing up and that's because we can't
resolve home header so what's the
solution going to be there the solution
is going to be that we need to restart
our webpack right so we didn't repack we
didn't restart webpack and that's why i
can't resolve that so let's go and do
yarn start again
and i'll
refresh we're good njwt is currently
empty because we haven't actually tried
to log in yet so let's go and log in and
see we get
so let's go bring in the login and the
j2at
from cart
and then down here in the use effect i'm
going to try to log in
but i'm also going to subscribe to that
jot
and that again that's going to take that
value and it's going to set that token
to that value or if the value is
undefined to nothing
and the cool thing here about subscribe
in rxjs is that it returns and
unsubscribe how cool is that and it just
so happens that the use effect is
expecting that we return a cleanup
function and it just happily maps to the
unsubscribe that we get back from the
job like that
cool okay so let's try it out and see
what we do
hey there you go okay so we're
successfully doing the login let's go
and actually test that and see if it
works over in our network panel
and we can look at our fetch and we can
see that we have a login
and we are sending the sally123 payload
and we are getting back the response of
the access token
looks pretty good and of course we're
seeing it over in the code over there so
thumbs up good to go
so now we're going to do is we're going
to build out the ui that's going to go
into the header over here it's not going
to go there yet we're going to go and
build those kind of locally within cart
and we're going to share those out with
the header the home page team that
manages that header and then they're
going to consume those and put those in
the header and it's all going to turn
into one nice
complete system
so
to make it nice i'm going to go and add
some icons so we need to go and add in
remix icons that's what i'm going to use
for
these applications and i'm going to
actually add that to all of them so i'm
gonna stop this guy
and i'm gonna yarn add remix icon to
that one
and i'm gonna grab that and then i'm
gonna go over to home page and i'm gonna
do the same thing there i'm gonna go to
pdp and i'm going to do the same thing
there
and the reason i'm doing it on
this side is that css is not something
you can share across module federation
it has to be
either css and js or js so that's not
the case in either of these cases i
don't think
so
this is so i need to add that dependency
to all of these applications so next
thing to do is restart everything
all right looking pretty good we got a
home page we got a cart page that's good
enough for now
and the next thing we need to do is just
make sure that we have the icons in
every place so i'm going to go to the
app.jsx file in all of our applications
and add the css for
the
remix icons
so back over here in app
add it again
[Music]
and again okay cool now we have nice
icons we can use in any application
so let's start building out our login ui
and one thing we're going to do is we're
going to share a custom hook around use
logged in so we can build that now so
we've got our
cart file in cart dot js
and i'm going to bring in react
and then down here i'm going to define
that we have a
used logged in
and it's going to return that logged in
state
and then it's going to set up a
subscription using use effect
to that jot
so first it's going to set the value of
logged in to whatever the current value
is of that jot and this little nice
double exclamation point basically
coerces it into a boolean
and then i'll do the exact same thing i
did with the subscribe over here
and there you go
okay so let's go back over to our cart
content and i'm actually going to remove
this auto login because we don't want it
to automatically log in because the
first thing we're going to build is our
login screen so i'm going to remove that
and then i'm going to go over here and
create a new file we're going to call
this login.jsx
and we're going to bring in use date and
that login and the use login from our
cart
and then we're going to create our
log in
and we're going to start off by getting
the logged in state
and ready to manage some state around
whether we want to show or hide this
little pop-up that we're going to create
then we're going to need some state to
manage our username and login so we
create some state for that so we've got
username and set username password and
set password as you generally do in
these situations
and i'm going to say if we're not logged
in then we're going to return no
so don't show anything
but if we are logged in we are going to
show a fragment so we're going to start
off with a little fingerprint icon
that's where you click on it to go and
fire up your login
and that's just going to be a span that
has within it
a
icon so unless you're using the i the
italic tag to become an icon as we
always do
and i'm going to add a id here because
we're gonna do some test automation at
the end of this show you how to test
this really cool stuff
and then if we click on that we're gonna
go and set that show login so we can
hide and show something we're gonna have
like a drop down
and so the drop down
is going to
switch based on show login
and it's
this is going to be basically kind of
relative positioned so
you know it eventually we'll move it
into the right spot but this is for
testing we don't want off the side of
the screen so i'm going to comment this
out currently
and then we need an input for our
username so i'm going to pop that in
there that input is going to have a type
of text
and a placeholder username it's going to
value username and then when it changes
it's going to set the username as
absolutely
regular react type stuff and it's going
to have some
nice
looking
tail one on it to make it look pretty
we do the same thing for a password but
in this case we're gonna give it a type
of password the value password and also
set password and again make it nice and
pretty tailwind style
and then finally we're gonna have a
button that's gonna be our login button
and also put an id on that so that we
can automate it later and it's just
going to call login with the username
and password the same login that we
ought to hear from cart
so let's take a look and give this a try
so the next thing we need to do is
import login
into our cart content and let's try that
out log in from login
and let's put it in there so i'm going
to put a div around the jot
before that i'm going to drop that login
in there since i got in the pace buffer
cool let's take a look oh okay uh okay
all right so i need to say if i'm logged
in then i return null ah here we go okay
cool so ah looking good
because i don't know that it's there
because i actually removed that use
effect from before
so let's go and figure that out so i'm
going to go and rebuild that use effect
that we had before to go and set the
token
but i'm not going to auto login
so now let's log in and yeah cool so we
know we're good we got the the jwt and
that's great okay so next thing we need
to do is build out that little mini card
so when i'm not showing the login that
means i am
logged in
and i want to show a little card icon
that shows me the number of items in the
cart and brings up a little pop-up that
gives you some details about what's in
the cart and allows you to check out and
clear the cart and all that kind of good
stuff but to build that we need to add
more stuff to our cart we need to manage
the cart much the same way actually we
do the jot so i'm going to go and create
a new behavior subject for the cart
and then we're going to add some
functions to get the cart
and add an item to a cart and clear the
cart
so let's start off with getting that
cart
so we have a function here get cart
and it does a
fetch just a
super straight get from the cart just
the way we did before and again
application json but this time we're
adding in that bearer so that would be
the bearer token with a dot value
and that's going to first off set the
value of the card by using car.next so
it's again a behavior subject like we
had with jot
and then it's going to turn the contents
of the cart as well so if you want to
get it that way that's fine too kind of
a nice nice dual purpose function there
of course now we want to go and enable
this git cart down here so once we've
logged in we want to automatically go
and get your cart and make sure that
that's up to date
but of course we want to make some money
so let's figure out how to add an item
to a cart
and that just takes an id
and in this case the exam is exactly the
same thing we're going to do a post in
this case because that was the route
that we created on the server side it
was a post and then into that we give it
the id but it also takes the same vera
token as we had before
that gives it its jot and that gives
your your identity so then we take the
return value which is just a response we
get the json out of it and we're
successful so we want to go back and get
a new cart uh you know we could take the
value that we got returned and that
would be the cart but
it's fine we can just make two requests
and then finally we need to do exactly
the same thing one more time for clear
cart so again same idea but in this case
we're going to use a delete method as
opposed to the post method
and again we're just going to go and get
the cart
so now we've got a basic set of
functions that allow us to manage a cart
let's go put a ui on it by creating
something called the mini cart
so we'll bring in our usual react use
effect and use state all the good hook
stuff
and we're going to bring in our cart
stuff so in this case that cart is going
to be our subscribable value as well as
the clear cart function that we're going
to need to use when we click on that
clear the cart button or really check
out two yeah whatever and then we're
going to get currency which is going to
allow us to
format currency but we're going to get
that from home so we're going to use
that module federation stuff to pull in
currency dynamically from home
okay so let's start building in our mini
card
so we'll start off by having our list of
items and we'll get that from our cart
and we'll have that a flag for showing
and hiding that cart because it's going
to have that little
icon there and you click on the icon see
the
the cart and click on the icon again
goodbye cart
and so we need to subscribe to that cart
so i'm going to use use effect in here
of course you could go and wrap that in
a custom hook if you wanted to but this
one is just going to do the same thing
as we have before so it's going to go
and get the cart items and then
subscribe this little nice optional
chaining here allows us to say well if
the cart value is null
then don't de-reference that to cart
items so it protects us from the value
of cart being null in the beginning
really nice
and of course we don't have any cart
that we want to say nothing
so let's start we're turning out our
jsx
and again we're going to do a fragment
because we're going to have that icon
and then we're going to have the content
so we'll start off with our icon
and we'll have that unclicked there
we're just going to show and hide that
cart state it's going to have an id on
it because again we're going to do the
automation stuff it's going to have a
shopping cart icon as opposed to the
fingerprint and it's going to have next
to it the length of items in the cart so
that's going to tell you how many items
you've got in that cart
you know this actually sounds like a
good spot
to try it out so i'm going to go over
here to cart content so i'm going to go
and import mini cart
from the mini cart
file and then i'm going to go and use
that down here mini cart
and let's see how we do
okay cool so we're not logged in it's
not persisted like that so i need to log
in and there we go so
sally has three items in the cart
awesome and if we uh try again and we
use maria
and here
maria has two items in the cart no thank
you chrome i'm good okay so it looks
like our cart icon is doing well and we
got the cart count going so thumbs up to
that so let's continue on and allow us
to show and hide the detail of what's
actually in the cart
so we'll go and create a show cart
again here we're going to have kind of a
pop-up thing the sum is going to be in a
fragment
and we're going to have a four column
layout
because we want the quantity the image
the name and the price that's going to
be the four columns
and then we're going to iterate through
all those so i'll use a map for that so
for the items i'm going to take each
item create yet another fragment and the
reason for that is because of grid
layout you want these to be at the same
level
all with each other so that's why the
the rack fragment in there but we need
the id so that's why it's react fragment
and not the react fragment placeholder
and then the quantity the image the name
and the currency that's in formatted so
let's go take a look
all right
again we'll log in sally cool and there
you go nice okay so sally has a dragon
wheel spinner a wheel spinner and a
gentleman spinner very cool
all right so of course she wants to know
what the grand total is how much
money am i spending
so we're going to add some more we're
going to go and add
three placeholder divs and then
essentially the grand total
and to get the grand total we're going
to give it a reduced function which is
going to take the
current reduced value which is going to
start at 0 and then add on every round
the quantity times the price so let's
try that out and see how we do for the
ground total
yeah looking good okay apparently she
owes us
20 bucks for three spinners okay cool so
now we need a clear button and a
checkout button
so to wrap those
i'm going to create a flex box
and then within that our first side of
the flexbox is going to have our
grow div on it and in there we're going
to have our clear cart so and again
we're going to have that on an id so we
can
automate that
and this is going to have some nice
tailwind formatting here i think we're
just going to put a border on that one
let's go take a look
yeah that's kind of nice i like that and
we can actually clear the card at that
point and now if i log in again we can
see sally has nothing in the cart so
that's cool that means that our server
is persisting the state of the cart
properly
awesome if we wanted to go and reset
this the car we just need to reboot that
server because it's all in memory
okay so now we need to put at the end of
this
we need to put our checkout button which
is basically going to do the same thing
you know
if you want to make a full e-commerce
system out of this then i guess you'd go
to shopify or whatever okay so
hit save there and then let's try one
more time and it looks like we're good
you know obviously don't have the cart
there because i cleared it the first
time but i think i think we're okay all
right so now the next thing we want to
do is integrate this back into the
header so that we get a coherent
experience for the customer and we get
that shared experience on every single
page so really cool
so the next thing we need to do is go
back over into our webpack config so let
me close out a few of these
files and we'll zoom in on that webpack
config that's part of the cart right and
so now the cart needs to expose a couple
things
it needs to expose the cart functions
that i had before so that i can
subscribe to the jot and the cart and it
needs to expose the ui components that
are the login and the mini cart
so cool we're exposing kind of both
functions and micro fe components here
so now we will reboot our cart server
and i'm going to copy these because i
need really all of the applications now
to be pointing each other so go over to
home
and
change the webpack config there so that
now home
can look at itself it can look at pdp
and it can look at cart
and pdp is also going to have the same
things i might as well just replace it
all in one one fail swoop
and let's see so i'm going to reboot
home
and i'm going to reboot
pdp
i made changes to both of those as well
okay cool
you know the only hassle about all this
is really the fact that the browser just
keeps popping up every time but
otherwise it's a really nice workflow
okay so let's go back up to home because
now we want to bring in those micro fees
from the cart and embed that in the
header
so let's bring in mini cart and login
from cart
and let's make sure that it works by
going over here to home
and as long as things don't blow up
you're generally speaking okay
and now i'm going to wrap this one in a
flexbox so i'm going to wrap the content
here
in a flexbox and well the first item in
that flexbox is going to be our our home
title or
the title of our app
and then i'm going to have a flex end
item
which is going to have our mini cart and
our login in it
i don't think it matters the ordering
there pretty sure it doesn't matter so
let's try it out
hey okay cool and now we'll log in
and looks great
how cool is that and it's so awesome i
love it
okay great
so let's change the css a little bit so
that we can make it look pretty so i'm
going to go back over here to our cart
and our login let's see mini cart
and there's a little bit of
justification that i got rid of there
the left and the cart
login yeah that look good bring in the
left you know i'm like like to make
things look nice so here we go so oops
i think that's another problem okay so
it's over there now uh let's go and go
back over to our header and make sure
this is relative
oh
look at that so nice okay awesome so now
we need to be able to add items to the
cart right of course so
we're going to use that add to cart
function over here in our home page
content to give us some away to add
items to the cart
and that jot function and that used
logged in to let us know if we want to
show those ad card ones because we are
logged in at this point we should be
able to add items to the cart so let's
go over back into our
content for home content
so we're going to bring in some stuff
from the cart we're gonna bring in add
to cart and also that use logged in hook
and i'll use used login and we're gonna
use that to toggle whether we're gonna
show
our add to cart buttons
okay so down here below description
we're gonna check to see if we're logged
in and if we are
then we are going to align on the right
hand side with a little padding on the
top a nice little button we're gonna add
some automation id to that so we can
automate it later where we can add to
the cart
all right let's refresh the page and
we're not logged in so let's log in and
oh my gosh okay cool i'm going to add to
cart
yes
all right here we go and look at that
and so now check it out we are sharing
state we're sharing the jot state so the
host page in this case which has that
home content is looking at the job
and seeing whether it's logged in or not
and showing these buttons and then when
it
needs to add an item to the card then
calls the add to cart function
which then fires off for the server and
then updates again that rsjs which then
updates that view so in fact here check
this out this is even cooler i can go
over here to rainbow flames and it
automatically updates so the whole thing
is reactive because you have that rxjs
subscribe mechanism so whatever state
manager you choose i strongly recommend
that you make sure that it's reactive
somehow and that you know all of them
are really at some level but things like
mobx and uh valshio
jotive these are all very reactive
mechanisms of course redux reacts a bit
more elaborate i would recommend using
redux toolkit if you're going to do that
but
they they all work which is really
important part because context also
works i'm not going to do that here but
context does work in these systems
okay so of course our car page is ugly
so we want to make sure that we have a
complete cart page so let's go back over
into our cart and update our cart
content
alright so starting from the top here
i don't need any of that anymore i'm
going to bring in cart and clear cart
from the car we're basically going to
redo the mini cart but just kind of writ
large i'm going to create some state
around the items and have a use effect
where we subscribe
to that value and of course i'm going to
use that nice optional chaining on there
to make sure that we have card items and
if we don't then we have an empty array
which allows us to safely render an
array map all right then down in here
i'm going to start with a fragment
and into that i'm going to use the top
of the page to be a grid of all of the
cart items and it's going to be a four
column grid layout i'm not going to
adjust the sizes like i did before
and then i'm going to go over to my mini
cart and i'm just going to grab
pretty much all of this
essentially exactly the same thing and
drop it in there cool
and let's take a look at our cart
so we haven't logged in let's go log in
and woohoo and check it out it's the
same data i added that rainbow flames
before and it's there how cool is that
okay
so
looks like we need a little bit of get
it all nice and aligned
yeah okay good
and then we need to add the buttons down
here for clear cart and checkout
so let's go back over here and
make sure that if we have some items
then we can show that ui
we're going to start off again with the
flexbox to allow us to put one button on
one side and one button on the other
side
and then you know i'm just going to go
and grab clear cart stuff because that's
basically exactly the same code so let's
go over here
and
let's see is that the balance that's a
balance yep okay cool and pop that in
there
and let's take a look
okay
refresh
cool awesome all right and i can clear
cart yep i can hey cool
all right so let's go have a look at
product
i'm gonna go over here to localhost 3001
and then do product id you know two sure
whatever
solid rainbow i like that one it's it's
solid and rainbow
so what i want to do is i want to show
you how to do micro fees across
different view platforms
so the way i'm going to do that is i'm
going to create an add to cart button
it's going to go in here so we want to
be able to add a card from the product
detail page but for some reason or
another the
folks on the add to cart button team
have decided to use solid js which is a
framework i love by the way so it's a
cool choice uh to do the add to cart
button and not react so the question is
can we get these two view frameworks
react and solid js to talk together and
i'm guessing the fact that i'm talking
to you right now is the answer is yes so
let's try this out this is going to give
us our
fifth application and our last tab
so let's go and
create yet the last terminal
and okay here
got a cart
and i'm going to do again pmpx
create mf app
and this time
i'm going to call it add to cart and i'm
gonna pick application and let's see
3003
and we're gonna pick solid js in this
time
and javascript and tailwind don't worry
if you don't know
solid js it's fine so we'll go into add
to cart
very easy and if you're familiar with
react actually solid js is very close to
react and i think there's a lot of cool
reasons to look into it on its own
so something you might want to look into
on your own line okay so here we go so
we're going to yarn start that up
and there we go so
it's kind of similar layout as we had
with the react stuff except that the
only difference here is that the
framework in this case is solid.js and
not react and that's actually the way
every single create mf app runs exactly
the same way and gives you exact same
output so that it's pretty easy to
compare these different frameworks
so now of course this add to cart
needs to be able to get access to that
shared jot and the add to cart function
so we're going to go down here to the
remotes and we're going to give it the
remote of cart
and i'm going to
restart that server
and into this directory i'm going to go
create a new file called add to cart dot
jsx
and you define a component in solid much
the same way you do in react so in this
case it's just a function and it takes
properties and returns some jsx now
there are no classes in this case that's
not something that solid.js supports so
it has to be a function
so in solid.js
there is a signal which is the
equivalent of a use state although it
can be global it can be anywhere it's
actually really cool
and then there's an effect
same kind of idea
but it's like use effect and then you
have a declarative style when it comes
to hiding and showing stuff and the tag
to hide and that tag to show is called
show so we're going to bring in those
from solid.js
and then from module federation and the
cart we're going to bring in the jot and
we're going to bring in add to cart
then we're going to create a signal for
login so it looks really similar right i
mean this you could imagine that to be
used but it's called create signal in
this case the really cool thing about
solid is that this could actually be out
here
it's really just a question of where you
want to store your state and it works
the same way in both cases so you when
it comes to state managers
solidjs most of that's actually built
into the core of state of solid.js so
you don't need a custom state manager
really cool so let's then do a create
effect
and that's going to do that same jot
subscribe thing and when the subscribe
fires telling us that we're logged in
then we set that signal
and then for the jsx
we are going to
return a show hide tag essentially it
has within it a button
that button has the same kind of
tailwind stuff as we had on before in
this case when you click it it's going
to do add to cart so there you go that
is our the complete sum total of our
solid js component
okay so let's go over here to app.jsx
and let's see how this is actually done
so the way that you render something
install js is you bring in render from
solid.js web
and then you render the component so in
this case that's that app that we had
before
so if we wanted to bring in our
component then we would import that here
the only thing is we're not bringing in
a header so we're not going to be
authenticated so it's going to be
difficult to test so i'm not going to do
that but what we need to do is basically
get this somehow so that it works in the
react context so i'm going to do that
and i'm going to create a function and
expose that and that function is going
to take two arguments the first is the
element that you want to attach it to
and then the second is the product id
which is going to go into id here
so i'm going to copy and paste this and
i'm going to create a new
file called place add to cart
dot js
and we're not going to bring in
index.css we're not going to bring in
this
but we are going to export
a default function
called place add to cart it's going to
take an element and it's going to take
an id
and it's going to render into element
and what it's going to render is add to
cart with that id
cool right okay so let's go and expose
this so we'll go back over to our
webpack config
and you know what we'll just
also expose add to cart
and also of course
place add to cart which is what we're
really going to use
that's js
let's see is that js
yep it is cool
all right so let's go here add to cart
and restart it because we need to update
that exposes and get everything going
and i'll see it's got a remote entry on
there
and it does it's going to tell us that
we've exposed the add to cart
and also the
place added cart so let's go back over
to our pdp app and import that so go
close out these files
and go to pdp
down to webpack config
and we're going to bring in
add to cart
and it's called add to cart and it's on
that remote entry
on 3003. cool
so now let's go back over to our
pdp content page
and we're going to bring that in
i'm going to bring in place add to cart
from add to cart
and let's go make sure that i get the
name right add the card
went back big there we go
cool
and we'll just refresh to make sure
everything's fine but of course we can't
find add to cart and why
because we haven't restarted the server
so let's go again to pvp
and
restart
and we'll refresh
and looks good so
fingers crossed things look good
all signs point to things being good
so we're going to do is we're going to
mount this on a ref
so we need an element
so we need to create a ref by using use
ref
and we're going to put that well put
that down here
graphics add to cart
and let's make sure that that works
yeah seems to be going okay doesn't have
any problems with that so let's add a
use effect
where if we have a current on add to
cart meaning that that the component is
mounted we have a unique element
then we're going to do place add to cart
with that current
element and then give it the id so let's
hit save
okay looks like we have an error so
let's go and look at the console and see
what that error is
go over here to console scroll up and it
looks like i messed up in my solid.js
code i just forgot to import add to cart
my solid.js so let's go save that
and go over here to
add to cart go into add
place add to cart yep absolutely so
let's go and import add to cart
you can't really use something until
you've imported it jack
so let's say save there and run and
we haven't logged in
so we're probably okay so far
cool can i do it yes i can that is so
cool
how awesome is that so now we've got a
react app
hosting a solid js component because
that's the what we decided to use for
that particular one and let's see did we
make a good choice
let's uh take a look and see
over on our network
take a look at the size of the payloads
here
so wow we're bringing a lot but
let's see place add to cart was 2.7
kilobytes so that's a that's pretty nice
we're bringing in not a lot
for
bringing in that add to cart and that's
one of the really nice things about
solid.js is actually creates very
very small bundles
all right so coming up next we are going
to take a look at how to do routing in
microfront ends and module federation
but before you do that if you are a get
kind of person source code control being
all that
i strongly recommend at this point to
commit what we currently have because
it's gonna get real
here real fast so we're gonna do some
pretty cool stuff
to address an issue that i want to talk
about right now so we've got
our three apps we got one on three
thousand one we got one on three
thousand two and one on three thousand
one
so let's go put those kind of in the
right order i guess three thousand three
thousand one three thousand two right so
let's say i wanna go and test out how my
home page connects to my cart as an
example right so
i'm logged in here
and
i'm adding stuff to my cart if i go over
just 3002 right now and then i see that
i'm not actually logged in anymore
because i'm not actually storing the
state and i'm getting a whole new page
refresh it's not actually a single page
application
so is there a way we can actually turn
these apps into a single coherent single
page application and this is a big deal
because what happens is when you
fracture one of these monolithic
applications into a set of smaller
applications yes they become a lot
easier to deploy but first you run into
the header footer problem that we have
before so you have to be able to share
components ie microfees like the header
and footer between applications
but also they become harder to test
right if you want to do a coherent test
where you start at the home page you add
something to the cart you may navigate
to another page eventually you'll end up
on the cart page and go through checkout
right
in order to get that done you have to
stage your whole system somewhere and
then put in your code for say the cart
as an example but keep all the code for
the existing apps and it just gets very
hairy and hard to manage
whereas if you had
all of them as essentially single page
applications where any of these
applications could vend all of the pages
for the other experiences
then
for example if you were working on a
cart and you want to make a change to
the cart but you want to run a smoke
test that ran through the entire system
you could do that
is it possible
yes it is let's go check it out and
that's why i'm saying we're going to
make some pretty significant changes
here although we have started ourselves
up nicely for this so in each one of
these applications
so cart
home and pdp
we have implemented
the interior of the
app as content so there's cart content
there's pdp content and there's home
content and it might have seemed a
little bit weird in the moment but i had
a plan like the cylons so
over here in webpack and fig
we're going to go and expose cart
content in the cart app so i'm going to
put in here cart
content
and then i'm going to get that from cart
content dot jsx
save that out and we will go and
restart cart so we're exporting that
and that seems to be okay so that's good
so now i'm going to do the same thing
over in
let's see what that is next home okay so
we've got home content so i'm going to
go to webpack config there
and home is going to export the home
content so i'll just replace out cart
with home just like that
and again save and now go to home and
i'll stop it and start it
now that looks good great
and then finally let's go over to pdp
and
go to its webpack config
and again we're going to expose out of
pdp the pdp content
and we'll go down to pdp and restart
that one
and that looks good
so here's what i'm going to do i'm going
to go over to the app for pdp
since it has react router baked into it
already
and i am going to copy some of this code
i'm going to copy all of it actually and
i'm going to take it over to home
and then i'm going to create a new file
in here called main layout dot jsx
paste that in there
and we'll call this one main
layout
and we'll get rid of that react render
dom you don't need that anymore
but what i do need now in
home is react router dom so we don't
have that so let's go over to home here
and stop that server and then yarn add
react router dom
and then i'm going to start that server
again
and now we start getting to the point
where we need content right so
we have pdp content from pdp
we've got home content
from home
and we've got cart content
from the cart
and now let's go take this main layout
and i go over here to app
i'm going to bring that in as the one
thing that we're going to bring in
and you know i'm just going to render it
right here we're not even going to have
an app anymore
now save that out and we're going to see
how we go this is basically a test to
see that all the connections are okay
looks like we have an exported main
layout so let's go over and so let's
just go make this an exported function
and then return this router
okay cool
and now at least we're getting a page
and that's good but we don't have a home
path so we're going to add a route for
the home so that would just be slash now
we're going to put in exact in there so
it needs to be that exact path
and that's going to be the home content
so let's save that out
and refresh and hey that's pretty cool
and if i do slash product
slash one
how cool is that i'm actually getting
the pdp out of the same app this is 3000
this is the home app but it's serving
the content for pdp that's really cool
okay so one more then let's go and bring
in cart so i'm gonna do slash cart and
we're gonna do cart content
okay cool now let me refresh and now i'm
gonna do cart
there you go awesome very cool so
it's not quite a spa yet because we
still need to do the linking component
of it so you so in order to get our spa
nav going we need to use link from react
router dom so let's go over to the
header and add the appropriate links so
i'm going to paste in react router dom
and i'm going to bring in link
and i'm going to put a link around
fidget spinner world
and that's going to go to slash
and let's see i'm going to add
a little divider there
and then i'm going to go and make
another link to
cart and we'll call that cart
let's take a look
cool and so i click on cart so i click
on this i go to the home page and if i
click on this i go to the cart and even
better so if i log in here
and i click on cart the login is
retained it is a full spa now how
awesome is that that is really cool okay
so
another thing i want to do is just make
sure that i have an id here for the
cart and that's just to make sure that
our automation works properly but i'm
going to go because i'm a little bit of
a stickler here i'm just going to go and
add a little bit of
padding or margin on the x
around that so just make it nice
and have that be a flex flexbox
yeah that looks good okay cool so now if
we want to click on one of these right
we want to go and use a spa link to get
to our product detail page so let's go
and change out home content
to
point at that product so i'm going to go
and
link in here to oh that actually looks
pretty good
and just wrap the product name in that
i'm also going to do the same thing for
the image
so if i log in
and then i click on solid rainbow i'm
still logged in everything great so i
have a spa coherent spa nav across the
app so that's awesome
and yes that seemed fast right but at
the same time we were pretty much set up
from the get-go to allow for that
so now let's answer one of the biggest
questions that i get when it comes to
module federation and micro fees which
is how to test this stuff and we'll
start off by looking at unit testing so
i'm going to close out all these files
and what we're going to do is we're
going to add a test to the home page
that will require the cart information
so we will need to mock the cart
so i'm going to first go to home and
then i'm going to stop the server and
i'm going to add
the testing library for react hooks
because we're going to basically create
a hook that depends on the cart count
and then i'm going to set up the adjust
environment by creating a new file
called jest.config.js
and i'm going to say that our
environment is the js dom
so now we're going to go and create our
used card count so i'll create a new
file
we'll call that use cart count and i'm
going to bring in use date and use
effect from react
i'm going to bring in the cart as you
would
and then i'm going to export
used card count and that's going to set
up some state that has the initial cart
items length in it
and then i'm going to return that count
and in the meantime i'm going to also do
a use effect
with no dependency array so it's only
going to run on startup
and then i'm going to subscribe to the
cart
and get that card items
and then set the count to the length of
those card items so that's pretty simple
one all i want is the number of items in
the cart pretty simple so how am i going
to test this
so i'm going to go and create a new file
called use cartcount.spec.js
and i'm going to bring in the testing
library with react hooks
and it's going to allow us to render a
hook and then call functions on it if we
want to but we're going to use this to
basically
trigger that subscribe
and then we're going to bring in our
hook
and then we're going to create our first
test so we're going to describe use card
count
and we're going to say that it should
return a cart count and we're going to
just get the result from a used cart
count and we're going to expect that to
be zero since there's no card currently
and we're going to mock the cart count
so how are we going to do that well
let's just do just mock and then give it
card cart
which is what we're looking for over in
used card count so is that going to work
let's give that a try so let's do yarn
jest
and we see that it can't find that
module cart cart
so
so the way that we can trick it into
believing that there's that module is to
create a new manual mock
for the cart so create a folder called
mox
inside that a
folder called cart
and then within that a new file called
cart.js
where we'll export
a default of essentially just an empty
object
let's give it a try
and there you go ran and passed so we're
going to add another test where we
essentially bump the cart count so we'll
add that in so use that cart count hook
and that's going to basically send us a
call back
in that use effect and then we're going
to call that back and say that we have a
new set of cart
items
so we need to store that callback
somewhere so i'm going to put that up
here and then i'm going to replace this
subscribe
with a function that takes a callback
and then sets that callback value
so let's try this
see if it works
all right two passes okay cool
so that's unit testing so you can mock
out these remote modules that's not a
problem so now let's talk about ede
testing
so the way that i'm going to do that is
i'm going to use cypress so the first
thing i need to do is add cypress
and then i'm going to open cypress by
doing yarn run cyprus open
and so what it's done is it's gone over
here and it's created a cypress
directory and in there there's a bunch
of tests we're going to do all the
integration tests and all that sort of
stuff we don't need any of that so we're
just going to get rid of that so i'm
going to create a new file in here and
we're going to call it ede
spec.js
and i'm going to describe my first ede
test
so now we have to record a test so i'm
going to go and create yet another
terminal where i'm going to run home
so i'm going to jump back into home
and yarn start it
and now i'm going to bring up the
cypress recorder which is an extension
on chrome and i'm going to do start
recording
then i'm going to log in
then i'm going to show the cart i'm
going to clear the cart
i'm going to go and add an item to the
cart
and then i'm going to go to the cart
page
now let's go take a look at what our
test has
all right that looks pretty good
so i'm going to stop recording and i'm
going to copy that to the clipboard
i'm going to go over here and i'm going
to say
it
should add
an item to the cart
all right so let's go over and look at
our cypress
and i'm going to run our ede spec
that's going to bring up chrome
all right and it didn't contain that
local host i'm not sure why that
happened so i'm going to go over and get
rid of this i don't think that's the
case anyway
so let's stop and then restart it
all right looking pretty good okay so
now what we want to do is we want to
test to make sure that we get this 599
value at the very end
so we're going to need an id on that so
let's go back over to our cart page and
make sure that we have an id on that
grand total
so we'll go down to cart content
and we'll scroll down here and we'll
make sure that oh we need an id on this
call that grand underscore total
excellent okay let's go take a look at
this
and we should be able to say cy.get
get the grand total and i'm going to say
that should
yep contain and what was the number we
wanted again 599. so let's take a look
and do 599 here
and see if we get
a passing test
awesome
light is green and that's an end-to-end
test
over multiple independently deployed
applications that is just super cool
all right so let's talk about what to
look for next when it comes to learning
module federation and micro fees and one
area in particular i think you should
have a look at is single spa so single
spa fits on top of module federation and
it gives you a way of making your
components
cross-platform so as i did with place
add to cart
that's a pretty simple hacky way to do
it single spa does it the right way it
actually goes and wraps all of the
different platforms it wraps their
components in kind of a uniform parcel
and then you can deploy those using
either a system.js or
using module federation which i think is
very easy
and then you can consume those in any
other application so you could parcel up
a view component and then reuse it in a
react component it makes it super simple
another thing i think you should keep an
eye on is bit this is a company that has
been doing
micro fe slash shared component work for
a long time and
they've been looking at module
federation so there might be some
interesting synergies going on there
so definitely
keep an eye out for micro fees when it
comes to bit
and then i often get asked like have you
actually seen this in the wild yet and a
friend of mine was working over at
lowe's and they've actually used the
module federation and micro fees to
create this really cool paint finder so
they've got a
an app and they embedded this paint
finder in it and now these two things
are independently deployable which is
really really cool so i'm
it is out there in the wild and that's
great
all right well i hope you enjoyed this
look into micros and you got a lot out
of it be sure to put any questions you
have in the comment section down below
and of course hit that like button if
you like the video all right enjoy your
future in micro micros